let's bring you some breaking news this
is on the case of archie battersby
you'll remember this case the court of
appeal today denying his family
permission to take their case to the
united nations this is after upholding a
decision that was made by the high court
to withdraw life support life support
treatment for the 12 year old he's
currently being treated at a hospital in
london aren't you relying on mechanical
ventilation since being admitted
hospital back in april and so the court
of appeal denying his family permission
to take their case to the u.n let's get
more from sadia chaudhary who has been
following this case um sally a lot of
people will be familiar with this story
but for those who aren't just remind us
of the background and how we got here
today
well this has been a very lengthy legal
battle already for archie battersby's
family who have been fighting to try and
uh keep treatment ongoing they've been
through three steps at the high court
two steps at the court of appeal and as
you mentioned on monday they lost that
court of appeal
decision which went towards the high
court decision last week which said that
treatment could be lawfully withdrawn
now the next step they had several
options on the table including taking it
to a european court but also the united
nations and i believe they attempted to
do that today and
the court of appeal has blocked that
decision which means the case now needs
to go to the supreme court here in
britain before it can get to the united
nations
a bit of background on this archie
battersby 12 year old boy who was found
at home with a ligature around his neck
by his mother was admitted to hospital
straight away this was back in april and
since then he's relied on mechanical
ventilation uh to breathe uh and we've
heard in numerous uh hearings throughout
the last few months about the extent of
medical intervention that is required to
keep archie uh going so things like even
things as minutes as administering
artificial teardrops these have to be
done monitoring blood pressure levels uh
checking his glucose levels lots of
things like that but particularly the
breathing assistance from the ventilator
now bart's uh health nhs trust
which is treating archie says that this
mechanical ventilation can now be
withdrawn because it has argued
previously that
his brain is so severely damaged that
there is no
chance of recovery archer's family say
that by withdrawing mechanical
ventilation that act will lead to
certain death they want archie to be
given more time and they've spoken to us
many times about this about giving him
longer giving him a chance
to fight back and to recover
they also crucially point to
articles 10 and 12 of the u.n convention
on the rights of people with
disabilities and article 10 article 6
apologies of the un convention of the
rights of children these are
obligations that the uk is under in
international law to ensure the survival
of children and to ensure that disabled
people share
equal rights as everyone else and they
therefore wanted to take this case to
the u.n because they say that it hasn't
been established in british courts but
as you've just
said there that the supreme court now
needs to be involved because the court
of appeal in this country has
blocked their chances of getting to the
un at this stage